gentle detangle of the good news comb
and with me at the desk a man with a
hair never out of place oh yeah rossi
ross matthews right i woke up like this
the second i read that i thought that is
true yeah no well i'm a little bit of a
mess when i wake up in the morning like
it's this going on well ross i bet
you're perfect all day long okay i'll
let you think that thank so much i know
you and i do actually all right well
we're so excited because we are
celebrating beauty all week long
and uh from top to tail we're serving up
a whopping 100 beauty tips so don't
blink or you might miss one in fact
i have a tip for you
right now let's see okay the next time
you look at olive oil look at it a
little differently
it's fantastic for cuticles and you can
put it on your skin your hand you can
astringent with a lemon and then
moisturize with some olive oil turn
yourself into a human salad trust me wow
it works huh okay i would worry that it
would clog my pores wouldn't you
i use vitamin e oil um pure vitamin e
oil on my skin all the time on my face
there's really nothing like it it makes
it so supple fantastic i just pictured
myself tonight with olive oil over my
hands like dropping the remote trying to
i'd like to see that i have another hand
tip though you know how you spf on your
face to block the sun rub a little bit
of that on your hands too because uh you
know when someone's had a little bit of
this when you look at their hands and
it's like oh hi grandma
you know i'm out look at those headlines
all right let's start with some style
news perfect dovetail
some people are reaching again back into
their closets and saying it's the 2000s
okay and vogue reports that this time
they're whipping out the old popcorn top
um it's a very stretchy s top it's like
an accordion almost yeah and a very high
like squish factor you can ball it up
throw it in a bag stomping it then put
it back on and it's as good as new
i have one here these you've seen these
right where they're like they're like
this big
and what i always liked about is that
they're so hopeful you know they're like
yeah but i could i could make it work i
could fit on you well i'll take that
challenge thank you very much let me
see okay
okay
she's a grower okay
not a shower
[Applause]
wait
how
how did it how
how'd you do that
look at that
wait i you know what i feel like i have
a whole new respect for these tops need
a little help
um got it
like it it does it goes right back to it
all right next we've got a senior high
school tradition i think you're going to
love drew good news network reports that
at north farmington high in michigan
seniors dressed up in costume for their
final id photo in their high school
career so
and boy they committed to these pictures
and we have some look we have a wayne
and garth
this is on their id
you remember that movie tangled with the
long hair look there's one
tangled
then we have a classic forrest gump
and also an alice in wonderland we have
[Music]
kyo i would do mine like um like
dorothy's bornak um from um uh golden
golden girls
remember dorothy b arthur that's who i
would want to do we could do sunny and
share we could do one together oh i like
that yeah who's sunny who's cher well uh
stay tuned
okay well
this story i also love as a um cat owner
because it's about the latest in dating
apps if you're a cat-loving single on
the prowl for the perfect date aha
there's an app for that really yes
upworthy reports that tabby dates is the
newest dating app designed just for cat
people and whether you have a cat
yourself or you just love kitties well
that could get a little creepy yup i
feel like you should own a cat um but
this app will get you a match and plus
you'll get deals on pet supplies
and get invited to special cat events
whoa whoa and if dogs are more your
thing guess what
hop on over to dig dates and that's a
dating app for dog people
frosty not in well i don't know i mean i
think okay good i think it's cute if you
like i just worried that i'd be
catfished no sorry i couldn't even get
that out
would you go on
what was it called kitty cat get it
we don't start a dating app called kitty
cat get it who in the heck is on kitty
cat get it get it get it
we know what you're getting we know
really weird fetishes oh my god i don't
know i'm in
[Music]